hi I'm Samuel I'm very glad to compete
with many other finalists of the
National Geographic competition in
Washington DC i'm also very glad to be
there with them and meet people that are
very interested in geography like myself
I live in Salem Oregon the capital city
and Oregon was a 33rd state admitted to
the Union the 45th parallel process
fails a statue of the Oregon pioneers
sits atop the Oregon State Capitol
building representing the hard travel of
many families who follow the Oregon
Trail which ends nearby my heritage is
Romanian my parents came from there and
immigrated to the United States I
visited there several times but the
place where I really like to go is to
see the Amazon rainforest of Brazil just
to to sit on those water lilies and and
see those dolphins jumping next to me is
just a big dream if I were to trade
places with a famous person I would
choose Christopher Columbus I would
choose me because she had the
opportunity to explore and sales all
around the world
my actions or geometry began when I
travel to places came home and then
reasons interest rates on the match then
I wanted to study new places that I
haven't been to so that when I hear
about a place I know where it is and
what's going on around in fact did you
know that antartica is the world's
driest continent what an honor to be
here with geography fans through all
around the country I want to thank my
parents and national geographic society
for supporters thank you
you